detailed realistic portraits masterfully
varied and duplicated that's the work of
the Chronos father and son painters were
among the most successful of the German
Renaissance the exhibition of their work
in Moscow is a sensation nine crown off
paintings unknown from Germany are being
shown alongside other works from the
father and son for the first time since
1945 those paintings had been secretly
kept in storage in Russia since the end
of World War two it's simply an
uplifting feeling to see this painting
for the first time since 1945
sainte-geneviève or when I see this here
the wonderful mayor of light say that we
have here this too is an absolute
highlight Adam and Eve in may of
nineteen forty-five the war in Europe
was over and the Red Army was
celebrating victory over the Nazis and
plundering German museums among the
artworks they looted were seventeen
paintings from the world-famous chronic
collection in gotha the paintings
disappeared for 70 years in Russia the
reasons for that are well known that was
the peculiar policy of the Soviet
leadership to keep everything under lock
and key even art historians have only
ever seen some of the paintings as
reproductions and old catalogs for
instance this work the burning of whose
books in front of a prince which was
considered lost for decades our most
important task today is to make all of
the artworks regardless of how they
ended up here in this museum accessible
to everyone whether ordinary visitors or
art experts beautiful widget leprechaun
olive but they'll only be shown in
Russia there are no plans to return the
looted art works to Germany for the time
being
you